oh hi everyone I'm Alana oh Charleson
and welcome to my gaming channel and
today I am doing an unboxing it's been a
minute since we unbooked something huh
Banda
it's been a while
but this with a very big thank you to
the team at limited run games is the
Dead Space remake collector's edition
they asked if I would like one a whole
while back and I was like absolutely yes
but I don't even know what's in it so I
think this is the Edition that has the
Isaac clock helmet which is what I'm
really really excited about so let's
jump in
I would love to do more unboxings
I'm just trying to ease back on correct
positions and stuff oh it does have a
helmet
this is the instructions
oh the Isaac clock helmet con wait let's
go first up Fox interior
beautiful I don't know what's going on
but it is nicely packaged and it sure
does smell like fresh Collectibles we
have this beautiful dead space steel
book here
lovely
this is so clean I really like the
design obviously no book in it oh sorry
no game in it as is the case with a lot
of collect positions these days but uh
very very nice
Sleek design there all right let's pull
out the box
oh it's not a box it's a book
I'm not even sure what this is
turn it up
I wonder if maybe this will be hot
probably oh it's like a folder of some
kind
wow how beautiful
a nice little display case with a shiny
shiny shiny lithograph print here that
is stunning
man I should display this somewhere this
is way too pretty
beautiful surprised it's not numbered
but maybe it is on the back I don't want
to take it out and ruin anything
and then we have this is really cool too
a poster fire it up for work
but play with fire and get burnt be
careful when handling fire
that is awesome like a little
advertising poster for the engineers
very cool very cool we have a very
recognizable
pin
awesome I think that'll go in like a bag
or a backpack because it's pretty big a
patch
also good for a backpack to be honest
says Planet crackers Starship ishimira
which of course is the ship Dead Space
is set on beautiful some sort of White
Contraption not sure what this is let's
find out it's a lot of fun in here so
it's probably something breakable oh
it's a marker
very nice little Maca Mini
statue here for reference this is really
solid like this is actually quite heavy
I don't really know how to describe that
to you but it is weighty um really solid
material and it almost looks 3D printed
but they've done a really good job of
making the inscriptions on the side of
this look
aged I wonder how they did it yeah it
looks like very different textures a lot
of very nice detail here I'm not sure if
that focused it might be too close very
cool I like that a lot and then we have
seems so funny I haven't seen
a CD case it's such a long time it's a
CD case it's like the way they all used
to look wow almost like opening a
cassette Dead Space original soundtrack
music
there
we have again love this simplistic art
we've got here
the planet beautiful so last is this big
fun thing which I'm gonna assume is
a helmet which is what I'm super super
excited about as much as I like all of
this stuff to be honest
um and yeah for anyone wondering I did
play the game I uploaded a photo
gameplay on the channel here and then
took that down
um just to encourage people to watch
charity stream that I did
um which is on my like stream upload
Channel with horror actresses Kate
Siegel
Sam's Point people are calling us the
scream Queens I have them uh come join
me to play horror games every now and
then and it's super fun so that is still
up on that channel I'll leave a link in
the description if you want to check it
out but um yeah I haven't finished the
game yet I played like probably like six
hours total I think and I think it's
fantastic it's have no unique takes
other than
it's not as scary as I remember it being
and I wonder if that's because of the
prevalence since Dead Space came out of
a lot of games where you don't
have uh combat it's a lot of running
like even some of the sessions of the
new Resident Evil games you're just
running away from stuff all the time so
I wonder if that kind of like shifted
how I feel about dead space
retroactively unfortunately but I still
think it's incredibly well designed
beautiful sound design and a lot of fun
to play which is also very important so
helmet time we have another one of these
cool safety posters here this one says
safety protects people quality protects
jobs
such as specific
era of like
propaganda
all right I gotta pull this off
unfortunately I'm gonna break it
anywhere to get the uh sticky tape off
for the helmet oh I really don't want to
rip it or like bend it
hate that they chose to do that to be
perfectly honest they wish that that had
been separate rather than stuck to the
outside of this box but
[Music]
I decided to update
okay okay
it's cool
dude it's so much bigger than I expected
what the hell nobody clicked that
nobody clipped the thing it's my honest
opinion
the weathering oh man okay here it is
here is the helmet oh dude
it's so rad
so it's very light
definitely just very plasticky but I
don't think it looks plasticky because
of the detail
I think they've done a great job with
the paint on this having it uh be like
properly shaded sort of copper
like you've got
low lights and highlights right next to
it here and then some scuff marks as
well that often I think people can do
really poorly but these ones look great
I think that's probably all just done in
metallic silver paint yeah a lot of a
lot of nice detail in terms of like the
sort of rusted sort of texture that
we're getting down here that I feel like
a lot of other things might miss
this
is stunning I'm very very happy with it
it again is very light because it is
made of plastic but it doesn't look
cheap and plasticky in my opinion
there is
the lights
beautiful LEDs in the back came with
batteries in it how awesome is that oh
my God
okay let's wear it don't imagine it's
gonna be comfortable it has one of those
um adjustable
headpieces inside so let's throw it on
ADD a head strap of course
make sure you Buckle them properly when
you're engineering of course
foreign
ly very sturdy like this thing
feels good oh my gosh and it's
comfortable like
nice to wear
I um if you didn't already know very
much now believe that Isaac clock would
not be able to see
which didn't really occur to me
previously of course it should have
but that man is not seeing anything
while wearing this but uh yeah I'm a
really big fan this is awesome this is
so so cool now just to figure out where
I'm gonna put all of it which is always
the struggle I want to make sure I
display things well I think I have a
spot for this you know let's go let's go
do it
I like that
it's perfect
oh thanks
what do you think Ninja
giving him sniff huh you like it does it
smell good
oh thanks for the help but thanks for
the help I couldn't have done it without
you oh thank you that is it for me today
everybody I'm Alana I will see you guys
next time bye